Hey youtubers it’s charlie and welcome to
another edition of Anime Club.
This one is all about Attack On Titan.
Since it’s been out for a long time on Crunchyroll
and now Netflix hopefully most of you have
had a chance to see it and I know a bunch
of you have read the manga too.
Before we get started, quick shout out to
the winner of my Forever Evil edition two
weeks ago.
Congratulations to Chloe Wright you win a
Twenty Dollar Amazon Giftcard and ItsybitsyIrishGirl
you get to pick a future topic for Anime Club.
I’ll be messaging you both on your channels
for details.This week I’ll be picking two
more Random subscribers from the comments
for the same prizes.
So first let’s talk about our top 5 Attack
on Titan anime moments, then I’ll do an
update on the live action film and season
2 of the anime series.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
season 1 of the anime yet.
Everybody bite your thumbs and let’s do
this!
For anyone that's curious I'm drinking Brainless
IPA during this.
Hopefully I won't be brainless by the end.
Number 5 - The Colossus Titan In Episode 1.
The promotional material had already spoiled
the titan’s for non-readers but just like
Game of Thrones Red Wedding, all of that did
nothing to dull the shock of seeing the giant
titan appear at the wall for the first time.
The other titan shifters would gradually appear
over the series and they were definitely WTF
moments, but after we got used to the shock
of the skinless steaming pile of scary.
The biggest thrill morphed into the mystery
of their identities.
Isn’t it funny that it’s one of the first
titan shifters we see, but we didn’t learn
who it was till way after the other titan
shifters.
Number 4 - The Female Titan Reveal.
I didn’t read the manga before seeing her
for the first time in episode 17.
There were so many red flags about the female
titan.
Mostly the fact that she looked like she was
designed to fight in close combat.
I really loved the flashbacks we got of Annie
being trained by her father later in episode
23, so much of the series is this really dark
psychological drama.
But unless you’ve read ahead in the manga,
she’s still stuck in that crystal cocoon.
The biggest questions I always had when each
of the titan shifters identities were revealed,
at least the sinister ones, was a big fat
WHY?!
I guess you could call it rage why.
Number 3 - Eren Gets Nom’d by a titan.
Worst cliffhanger in the history of cliffhangers.
It was such a huge moment I just screamed
in my chair for a week until we found out
what happened.
This actually brings up a minor complaint
of the series in that the intro’s and the
outro’s make it feel like each episode has
very little new content.
Like almost half the episode is spent talking
about the previous episode and the next one.
So this became a meta WTF moment because of
what happened to Eren and the giant middle
finger they gave us with that cliffhanger.
Number 2 - Eren is revealed as a titan shifter.
He was the protagonist of the series, so he
had to come back somehow.
Before the epic shifter reveal I thought he
would just cut his way out from the inside.
The series doesn’t do a good job of explaining
the Titan’s digestive systems.
In my head I kind of thought they were like
mini sarlacc pits.
Where people would usually just die from the
impact of falling down their throats, or they’d
die from starvation if the Titan’s didn’t
vomit them back up.
Somebody should start an extra credit course
at school for Titan Biology.
I could do an entire video just for Eren,
he’s not my favorite character.
Mostly just because he seems so reluctant
to embrace his new abilities.
He spends the rest of the season up to his
fight with the female titan just trying to
decide how he feels about it.
Which is why he’s such a terrible fighter
when it comes time to lay the smack down on
Annie.
Something every Anime, Science Fiction and
Fantasy series needs is a montage where the
hero tests their abilities and learns how
to control them.
I feel like Eren waited a little too long
to do that.
It’s like his montage happened while he
was getting his ass kicked by Annie.
I was actually kind of surprised that he was
able to defeat her.
But to be fair he had the help of the survey
corps.
And my number 1 WTF moment - Titan in the
wall.
This raised so many questions like are all
of the walls made of titans?
Is the city just wall to wall titans?
Who put them there?
and most importantly why are they there?
It seems like now someone has a grand plan
for all the people.
They’re not the only city in existence,
so we still need to learn of all these shifters
came from another group trying to subjugate
the city.
So many questions for Season 2.
Let me know what your biggest WTF moment was
from season 1 and what is the biggest question
you want to see answered in season 2?
We should all go ahead and pour one out for
fallen comrades.
Here’s a quick update on the live action
movie before we start talking season 2.
Right now they’re getting ready to start
filming this summer with an expected release
date of Summer 2015.
If you saw the Subaru Commercial with CG titan’s,
the movie director worked on it.
But they don’t know if the titan’s in
the movie will look the same as those.
No cast has been announced, but since were
getting so close we should find out who they
are pretty soon.
Now here’s an update on Season 2 of the
Anime Series.
The studio that produced series 1, Wit Studios,
isn’t going to start working on Season 2
till either late this year or next year.
Meaning it’s going to be a while before
we see it.
They said this year they’re actually producing
a different anime series called Hōzuki no
Reitetsu.
So if you liked the animation on Titan you
should check it out.
I probably won’t wait a full week to post
my next anime club video.
I want to do a review of Miyakaki’s The
Wind Rises.
It just opened in theaters wide this weekend.
So you should all be able to find somewhere
to see it where you live.
Remember I’ll be picking two subscribers
randomly from the comments to be this week’s
giveaway winners.
I’ll announce who you are in that review
video.
I’ll try to post it Tomorrow Morning.
Right now click here for my top 5 evil anime
characters and click here for my top 5 Miyazaki
films.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!